thirty years ago we discovered man-made
chemicals had punched a hole in the
ozone layer is that hole here to stay
waiting around to kill us today we're
trying hard to find out
morgen santa is about to test an
experimental plane perfect for sampling
ozone we think we can go as high as 90
thousand feet that's the big boy
territory that's where things can go
wrong very very quickly if we lose cabin
pressure then the pilots could very
easily pass out and we don't have any
automatic systems to recover from that
now a glider might sound like a
dangerous choice so high up but gliders
don't have engines which means they
can't pollute the team samples
[Music]
the purl and glider uses air rising over
the southern Andes to reach
extraordinary heights
[Music]
they were speed 70 knots looking
beautiful very graphic yeah
fifty-two thousand feet up makes this
the highest glider flight ever but
you've got to get this high to get a
great picture of the ozone layer the
good news is that thanks to a global ban
on ozone harming chemicals it looks like
the whole is healing up our shield is
regenerating
[Music]